you are about to enjoy a free preview of
marvel studios chongqi and the legend of
the ten rings
[Music]
after my mom died
my dad started my training
[Music]
from sun up to sundown i was taught
every possible way to kill a man
oh
by the time i was 14 i could barely
remember what life was like before she
died
that's how old i was when he sent me on
my first assignment
i was willing to do anything he wanted
if he asked me to burn the world down i
would have asked him for vegetarian
roll out of the chicken so i can only
offer you beef or vegetarian
um
vegetarian will be great same okay thank
you
so oh
we're out of the vegetarian too
now we only have beef
beef
because that's all you have right okay
you'll have the beef yes and and the
beef
two beeps
did you go through with it
i knew that i couldn't go back to him so
i just
ran
i know this is a lot to dump on you
i'm sorry about you mom
i should also probably mention that
my name's not technically sean
what
what is it
it's
shanxi
yeah you changed your name from shang to
sean
yeah i don't i wonder yeah i wonder how
your father found you i was 15 years old
all right what is what is your name
change logic you going into hiding and
your name is michael you want to change
it to
michelle that's that's not what happened
it's like hi my name is gina i'm gonna
go into hiding my new name is gina
yeah okay oh yeah you can hear me
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
don't need
we
do
with a teacher
okay
seems like a nice fella
and this elevator is definitely up to
code it's absolutely no chance of it
just falling off the side of the
building
oh my chinese sucks oh oh all good i
speak abc oh great i'm john john john
john welcome to the golden daggers club
okay let's get you ready to fight wait
what well multi-platform global
operation every fight live stream on the
dark web thousands of viewers placing
beds as we speak this is going to take
your brand to a whole new level i think
there's been some sort of confusion i
like your spike face they're my guts
usually you gotta fight your way to
central ring but a viral style like you
found a line baby i'm not here to fight
anybody okay i'm looking for my sister
never heard of her we just lost a fight
at the last minute so you get the next
slot
nice one helen
is he'll be funny in one of these
oh no no no these are like low level
fights you're
gonna be fighting
up there
[Applause]
you want me to show you how it feels
no wrong
i always bet on asian
oh my god yeah look i'm not going up
there okay oh it's too late to back out
now we already committed bro what you
signed the contract remember your name's
on the roster the bets are piling in
really what's our cut oh it's huge it
doesn't matter it matters
dude i saw you fight five assassins and
a giant romanian with a razor voice on a
moving bus this is just one guy just do
it then we all get paid and then i'll
help you find whoever you're looking for
come on you got this got this don't be
nervous thank you yeah yeah
[Applause]
how's the jar
maybe you'll start controlling those
punches like we practiced
love that
guy
i'll take your shirt off
ladies and gentlemen
the fight we've all been waiting for
the incredible viral sensation
all the way from san francisco usa
it's
blackboard
what happened in your shirt
[Music]
his opponent for tonight
it's macau's own fearsome killer
[Music]
[Applause]
see what happens next order the entire
movie marvel studios xiangxi and the
legend of the ten rings